morning everyone the business and Energy
Secretary Grant chaps has described his
horror at a report that British gas
contractors have been forcing entry into
vulnerable people's homes to fit
prepayment meters British gas parent
company centrica says it's suspended the
use of Court warrants that allowed
forced installations after an
investigation by the Times newspaper in
response to that investigation Mr shaps
has tweeted I'm horrified by the
findings of this investigation by the
times I've asked energy Minister Graham
Stewart to hold a meeting with the
company in the coming days and he will
be demanding answers to ensure this
systemic failure is addressed
let's get more should we Matt standing
by for us outside cedrica's headquarters
in Windsor hello to you good morning uh
what on Earth is going on here
I mean it's a fairly jaw-dropping story
actually in the times this morning
finding that debt collector is working
for British gas have been obtaining
Court warrants to forcibly enter the
homes of sometimes vulnerable customers
and install prepayment meters now the
issue of prepayment meters has been in
the news for some time after it emerged
towards the end of last year that a
number of energy companies were using
these kind of practices to put sometimes
very poor struggling customers onto
prepayment meters and clearly what
happens is if they are suddenly unable
to put money in their meter well then
their energy supplies are cut off and so
for that reason the Energy Secretary
Grant chaps wrote to energy companies in
January
urging them to stop the practice but
what's happened is the times has gone
undercover with a company called arvato
Financial Solutions which is a debt
collection agency used by British gas
and it's fined some really quite
alarming practices including for example
bonus culture in which there were
bonuses given to staff for installing
these prepayment meters which therefore
caused them to perhaps disregard the
vulnerabilities of some of their
customers people with disabilities
people with young children for example
and actually it's possible that some of
the practices are in breach of the
regulator off gems licensing conditions
the off-chem has told the times in a
statement that the concert their their
story is alarming and that off gem are
urgently investigating and the owner of
British gas centrica has said in a
rather lengthy statement that protecting
vulnerable customers is an absolute
priority and we have clear processes and
policies to ensure we manage customer
debt carefully and safely more broadly
they said there are clearly significant
challenges around affordability and
unfortunately we don't see that changing
anytime soon we need to strike a balance
between managing spiraling bad debt and
being aware that there are those who
refuse to pay and those who cannot pay
but I also thought it was notable okay
that British gas said in a statement to
the times that this is not who we are
this is not how we do business except
the problem is it rather seems that
that's exactly how they were doing
business until such time as a newspaper
uncovered the practices
okay for now thank you
well that investigation into British gas
comes is the cost of living crisis
continues to grow later on today the
bank of England is expected to raise the
official base rate of interest for the
10th time in a row it's currently at
three and a half percent and is expected
to increase to four percent after a
meeting of the monetary policy committee
it's already at its highest level for 14
years and we'll have more on this with
our business presenter Ian King a little
bit later on in the program
meantime water bills in England and
Wales are also set to rise in April
they'll go up by seven and a half
percent the biggest jump in almost 20
years it'll mean the average household
will pay 448 pounds a year water UK says
it reflects higher energy costs for
suppliers
vulnerable children should be supported
to stay with their families in safe and
loving homes under new plans being set
out today the government's offering more
help to family members who take over the
care of a child including aunties uncles
and grandparents to keep them out of the
Care System One grandmother told us she
was paying 2 000 pounds a month to care
for her grandson here's Jason Farrell
right do you want to get your scooter
Sam who we won't identify could no
longer be cared for by his parents what
good hand-holding so his grandmother
Sandra stepped in one for you and one
for the Ducks please he was just 14
months old and came with symptoms of
trauma
shall I watch the scooter
Sandra's retirement plans suddenly took
a turn
so life very difficult it's very
different
um I'd planned for five years time to
retire I can't do that any longer
because I've spent most of my savings
now to bring him up as far as he has
with incurred expenses from nursery
school and his therapy it was just under
2 000 pounds a month there was no
support at all I found those first
couple of months if I'm honest
horrendous absolutely horrendous
a review Into the care system published
last year found kinship carers such as
grandparents and aunts were undervalued
and today the government is introducing
measures to support wider family
networks to keep children out of the
care system
with 45 million pounds earmarked for
early intervention for struggling
families the government will provide
training and support for kinship carers
and 25 million pounds is being invested
in recruiting and retaining Foster
carers
the lib Dems say it's not enough and
want to give kinship carers financial
support in line with that offered to
foster parents their leader Ed Davey was
himself raised in part by his
grandparents that's my
Nana and Granddad he lost his father
when he was four and his mother died of
cancer when he was 15. the pressure on
his grandparents losing their daughter
and raising him is something that stays
with him
and I wrote this essay for my assessed
English O level
and it was all about
this how it was coming home with
attention and knowing what my mother was
going through
and uh
my my teacher said he couldn't Market
because it was so Raw
because it's that mother-daughter
relationship as well which is and I was
right in the middle of it yeah
um but it was you know they were both
wonderful lovely people well all three
of them my mother was special and uh
it's just one of these things but that's
why kinshukara is so important
because you don't have that with anyone
else
this way there's a record number of
children in the care system and it's set
to rise the question is will this extra
help for children like Sam be enough to
reverse that Trend Jason Farrell Sky
News
Sarah actually here in the studio with
us a little bit later on talking more
about that story meantime almost a week
on on the mystery of a missing mum of
two in Lancashire remains unsold Nicola
Bully's parents say they fear Somebody's
gotta they've asked police whether there
is any chance of her being taken after
the 45 year old vanish while walking her
dog a partner of 12 Years Paul Ansel has
said her daughters are desperate to have
their mummy back home safe with them he
said they're living through a Perpetual
hell and utter disbelief
police divers drones dogs and
helicopters and Mountain Rescuers are
now involved in the search in Lancashire
for Nicola Lancaster Police say they are
extremely concerned about Miss Bully's
welfare friends and family have also
been part of a widespread Community
search
Nicola went missing early on Friday
morning after traveling from her home in
Inskip to the nearby Village of Saint
Michael's on wire approximately a 10
minute drive
she dropped her children off at school
before heading on the walk with her dog
she then met her way onto a footpath by
the river where she was last seen at
around 9 15 a.m police later found
Nicholas mobile phone on a bench on a
footpath still connected to a conference
call and her spaniel was also found
nearby
centralized search efforts are being
conducted around the area near the bench
where her phone was discovered meanwhile
police dive teams Mountain rescue
volunteers and local community members
continue to search along and in the
river wire
We'll Be Live at the scene in just a
short time meantime a royal Rouse
erupted in Australia after it was
announced that the Queen's image won't
be replaced with that of King Charles on
its five dollar banknotes instead it'll
feature the first Australians Nicole is
standing by for us this morning um hello
to you Nicole a very good morning to you
um tell us more about this another snub
for the Royals
well first of all it's come as a big
surprise to many Australians but most
people I've spoken to have said that
they support it it is a significant
change for there to be no member of the
royal family on an Australian banknote
and this will take a number of years to
come into effect though in the meantime
King Charles will be on Australian coins
but it's a real sign that in this era
after the death of Queen Elizabeth II
that change is afoot in Australia this
decision was made by the Central Bank
along with the support of the federal
government let's take a listen to what
Australia's Treasurer had to say about
it
the Monarch will still be on the coins
but the five dollar note will say more
about our history and our heritage and
our country and I see that as a good
thing
this is much more than a debate about
simply a five dollar note it will be
replaced with an image that means
something to indigenous Australians and
that is one of the central debates here
in this country this year later in the
year there'll be a referendum about an
indigenous voice to parliament in
Australia it's already proving
incredibly divisive the big question is
how to close the gap between the
appalling living conditions that
indigenous Australians live in compared
with non-indigenous Australians
okay thank you
in the US family and friends of Tyree
Nichols have attended his funeral in
Memphis the US vice president Kamala
Harris was among those who delivered
speeches describing Mr Nichols death
after being beaten by the police as a
violent act that went against the police
mission to keep people safe James
Matthews hasmore
[Music]
this was a funeral and far more
its congregation voiced our country's
concern at what had brought them here
Kamala Harris
the vice president grieved with the
mother of Tyree Nichols and spoke for a
government
their brother
through an act of violence
at the hands and the feet
of people who had been charged with
keeping them safe
we were sure in fresh pictures of Tyree
Nichols he wasn't the only victim of
police violence represented here at his
funeral I know the family of George
Floyd is here stand up relatives of
others who died previously traveled to
Memphis come on it was the past and
present standing side by side for change
in future
we have to fight for justice
we cannot continue to let these people
brutalize our kids
in the wake of the video release of
Tyree Nichols fatal beating the Memphis
fire department has announced that three
employees have been sacked for failing
to assist him
this after the firing of the five police
officers facing charges of second-degree
murder
they were addressed directly at his
funeral here in the city that saw the
assassination of Martin Luther King a
civil rights leader who had a dream
in the city
with a dream
laid down and shed his blood
you have the unmitigated gall
to beat your brother
chase them down and beat them some more
and she lay her son to rest the mother
of Tyree Nichols talked politics
urging the adoption of the so-called
George Floyd Bill to limit police
immunity it was a mother's plea to a
nation's politicians we need to get that
bill passed amen because if we don't
know that blood the next child that dies
that blood is going to be on their hands
yeah James Matthews Sky News Washington
[Applause]
taking you to South Africa in just a
moment but let me tell you some breaking
news in the last few moments shell
profits increased by have a guess
84.3 billion dollars that's
68.1 billion pounds due to Soaring oil
prices that according to Shell within
the last few moments no doubt the
government will come under pressure for
that windfall tax again so those are the
latest Figure 6 billion pounds and
change uh the profits for Shell up 53
also making news for you this morning
and a 32 year old man has been charged
with the murder of Natalie McNally who
was stabbed in her home in Northern
Ireland is due to appear in court today
Ms McNally was 15 weeks pregnant when
she was stabbed
police in eastern Ukraine say a Russian
missile has destroyed an apartment
building and damaged seven others in the
city of kramatosk at least two people
were killed 20 injured and it's likely
more are stuck beneath the rubble
microplastics used in food packaging and
paint have been found in human veins a
new study suggests microplastics can
pass through blood vessels to vascular
tissue but scientists said it was not
clear yet whether what the implications
are for human health
as promised let's take you to South
Africa where ongoing power blackouts are
threatening to the economy a
protest March is taking place in
Johannesburg this morning as the country
has warned the energy crisis could last
another two years well joining us now is
yusra al-bagaya hi uzra I mean I've
followed this story quite closely
weirdly it's called load shedding I
believe even though it's a blackout and
it doesn't look as though the
infrastructure can cope
no it doesn't at all I mean we could
very confidently say that South Africa
is in a state of infrastructural
collapse at the moment and there's a lot
of discontent and dissatisfaction in the
lack of clarity around how this will be
dealt with and when people will find
relief from these ongoing power cuts and
today people are planning to march here
to eskom's headquarters escom is the
sole power producer of the country and
this is the megawatt park which is
industrial which is the headquarters of
the entire operation they're they're
calling for consistent reliable and
affordable electricity supplies
something that the country hasn't seen
in the last few years and earlier this
week's escom announced that they'd be
implementing stage six load shedding now
what that means is up to nine and a half
hours of no power and that doesn't even
include the the unscheduled power cuts
that we're seeing around substations
breaking down around power surges taking
local local areas Off the Grid and it's
really impacting all all walks of life
people here for people the economy is
being heavily impacted economists
estimate that the economy is eight to
ten percent smaller than it would be if
it were not for escom's failings that
the economy is losing up to 200 million
dollars over 200 million dollars in GDP
per day people's local businesses are
being impacted people's daily lives are
impacted but more than anything it is an
issue of life or death public hospitals
here are collapsing under the stream of
running on generators for for a majority
of the day and the minister of Health
reported only 43 of South Africa's 400
hospitals are exempt from load shedding
so people have a lot to protest about
okay indeed so um keep us updated if you
will thanks and I thank you
still to come on the program for you as
promised the lib Dem leaders that Ed
Davey will be here with us also speaking
to the former NHS Chief exec Lord Nigel
crisp about the crisis basing the Health
Service and just after eight joined by
the shadow leveling up secretary Lisa
nandi
further questions swirling for the Prime
Minister about what if any knowledge he
had of bullying allegations against his
Deputy Dominic Raab before he was
appointed the Deputy Prime Minister and
the Justice secretary here's what
happened at pmqs yesterday
how would he feel if one of his friends
or relatives was being forced to work
for a bully simply because the man at
the top was too weak to do anything
about it
Mr Speaker I I noticed he didn't say
anything about why one of his own MPS
describes being in his own party
[Applause]
he's made aware of formal complaints I
instructed a leading independent KC to
conduct an investigation because I take
action when these things happen
okay let's uh look at that more detail
Dave Penman is General Secretary of the
first division Association Union High
it's good to see you thanks very much
indeed for joining us so talk to us in
more detail about that and what kind of
uh an impact has Dominic Ralphs um
alleged bullying had on civil servants
in his Department well I think it's
important that we don't go into details
of the allegations they're being
investigated and confident
confidentiality is critical I'm asking
about the impact
um I I've spoken to people who are civil
servants uh working and have worked for
Dominic Raab who have suffered Mental
Health crisis have
um uh uh lost their careers essentially
because they've had to to move and and
change jobs billing has an enormous
impact on individuals it's about an
abuse of power and the in many cases
there's no greater power Dynamic than
someone who is a government minister or
a deputy prime minister and the civil
servant and where that gets abused they
can have significant consequences for
individuals how many people are we
talking about I don't know exactly there
are eight complaints of which we
understand I think a couple of dozen
civil servants involved in it it covers
three different government departments
it covers a period of about four years
and in any other employment context if
that was you me or anyone else in the
workplace up and down the country the
employer would consider suspending
someone because with allegations so
significant you have to have regard for
your current employees and whether
essentially you're putting them In
Harm's Way if potentially someone who is
a could be a prolific bully is still
allowed to be in the workplace and
that's what the Prime Minister should
address and address lots to talk about
there let me unpack it if I may so you
say at least eight allegations covering
a couple of dollars and civil servants
um what has been the outcome for some of
those civil servants who say they've
lost their careers yeah if if you're in
a workplace where you're being bullied
where you're The Daily Grind of coming
to work destroys your mental health then
that is an impact on your career but you
know these jobs working with ministers
in many ways are the Pinnacle of a civil
servants clear it's at the top of the
Civil Service doing some of the most
important jobs and civil service and to
leave that as part of your career or be
forced out because you can't cope with
it it's hugely damaging to your career
and and your life well let me put this
to you uh Jacob risma was where you are
a couple of days ago and this is what he
had to say
is it reasonable to demand from senior
and well-paid professionals a level of
good service and then you have to judge
whether that line has been overstepped
but I I do worry that we are getting a
bit snow flaky about this
bit snow flaking I was astonished by
those comments Jacob Lee smog was leader
of the House of Commons I know that he
met with people who were the victims of
bullying in the Commons he's had
firsthand what it's like to be on the
wrong end of building in to talk about
snowflakeery in those terms is just
astonishing from someone in his position
this this sort of behavior destroys
lives I mean it's not just about careers
people's lives and their mental health
are at risk when they are subject to
systematic bullying and to belittle it
in that way is absolutely outrageous
from a former leader of the house and
cabinet minister let me put this to you
from the education secretary Julian
Keegan
I think actually it was Dom himself who
instigated this investigation
um so that's ongoing I sit around the
cabinet table and you know don't see
don't see that right I don't see any you
know I feel very comfortable with my
colleagues around the cabinet table
doesn't see any bullying billing is
about the abuse of power so the power
dynamic between the Secretary of State
for education and the Deputy Prime
Minister is very different from the
power dynamic between a minister and a
civil servant so Vanessa should know
that when they talk about they haven't
witnessed it they wouldn't witness it
because they are in a different position
from a civil servant or someone who can
be bullied by someone as powerful as a
deputy prime minister why should he be
suspended because you or I or anyone
else would be if we were in that
situation why should government
ministers be any different if any
employer faces significant allegations
against someone they have to look at
their current employees and if you're
faced with eight separate allegations
from three different parts of your
organization over a period of four years
involving dozens of people that suggests
there is a real issue there and a real
danger
um for the health and safety of com
staff until you can established Gil or
instance you have to protect your
current Workforce why spiritual number
10 about this this morning and they said
that there's a long-standing principle
that ministers should continue to carry
out their duties while an investigation
is ongoing the the prime minister is
also Minister for the Civil Service he
has an obligation to civil servants if
it concludes at the end of this
investigation that it's correct that
Dominic Rabb is a bully that all of
those allegations are correct what it
means is in the meantime he has been
allowed potentially to bully civil
servants and whale sees uh that the
secretary of state that is the issue
that the Prime Minister needs to contend
with he wants this power he has decided
he will not allow an independent system
to deal with complaints and with that
power comes responsibility including
protecting current civil servants
friends of Dominic Robb who work within
government including two senior civil
servants saying that this is a clear
attempt by politically motivated
mandarins to get him that's
extraordinary and it couldn't be further
from the truth in actual fact I've
spoken to people who didn't raise
concerns at the time because they
understood the political impact of it
they were reticent a bit challenging
Behavior because they understood at that
point in time it would be seen as a
politically motivated attack civil
servants are politically impartial they
want to serve the government of the day
and do the best job but they have to be
protected and work in an environment
where they are not bullied for doing
that and to suggest that they are
actually got some political motivation
I'll be really seeing two dozen civil
servants in three different government
departments over a period of four years
I've got together with some massive
conspiracy that just doesn't uh it's so
incredible why have they waited years to
come forward because it's really
difficult to raise complaints again I've
spoken to some of the people involved in
this and they said they'll look at what
happened with pretty Patel the Prime
Minister was forced into an
investigation he sat on that report for
six months and when he was forced to
actually conclude on it he ignored the
recommendations that she had bullied
civil servants and breached the
ministerial code so they got a clear
message the only way you can complain
about a minister is to go through the
Prime Minister and that prime minister
was not interested in allegations
against his political allowance what do
you think he knew when do you think this
prime minister knew about allegations
against Israel the reports are that he
was briefed and if you look look at what
he says he's he's telling us what he
doesn't know he hasn't telling us what
he does no I think the Prime Minister
needs to come clean it would be normal
practice that when a prime minister is
appointing cabinet ministers he would be
told of any concerns whether that was a
formal complaint or not he may well have
been aware that there were concerns
about dominance May well that's you
don't think well we don't know because
he won't answer the question he repoint
blankly refuses to say whether he was
told about informal complaints about
Dominic Rabb and if he was what did he
do with that did he say that wasn't
important if those concerns were raised
about his behavior that really didn't
matter what was more important was given
a job to a political Ally we need to
know and the reason why benitino is
because the Prime Minister has to decide
on this investigation the Casey involved
doesn't decide on it he only establishes
a fact so the prime minister is the one
who in at the end we've just had this
from the PM's press secretary so let me
put this to you and see what you say in
the result the pream was not aware of
any formal complaints at the time of
appointing Dominic Brad yes that's what
he keeps saying he keeps relying that no
because there were no formal complaints
because the only way you can make a
formal complaint is for the prime
minister of the day to agree that there
would be an investigation he's not been
asked whether there were formal
complaints he's asked about whether he
was aware of any informal concerns about
Dominic Rabb and once again he is
refusing to answer that point let me ask
you one final question if I may um we
had labor on the program yesterday they
said that he needs to be suspended as a
matter of urgency because there are
concerns about uh not all not only the
welfare but also the safety of those
people in his department is that going
too far it's not going too far that's
what would happen to anyone else in this
country why should government ministers
be exempt from what would be the rules
that apply to everyone else faced with
significant allegations of bullying it
would be normal practice to suspend
someone until such times have you been
able to establish the the whether they
are valid or not that's what should
happen in this case okay it's it's great
to talk to you thanks very much for
joining us thank you all Mr Rob has
always insisted that he has behaved
professionally at all times in denying
the allegations of bullying and
intimidating Behavior out we will
continue of course to cover that story
for you here on Sky News quick look at
the weather for you now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days generally mild and mainly
fine in the South but the north can
expect more Wind and Rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
again everybody Rishi sunak is under a
growing pressure as you know to explain
what he knew when about bullying
allegations surrounding Dominic Raab a
deputy prime minister uh joining us is
leader of the lib Dems at Davey Heights
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program uh
what needs to happen as far as Dominic
Raab is concerned in the interim well he
should be suspended from his job I think
viewers will be shocked that these
hugely serious allegations up to 24
allegations we're told of of bullying
um and he's still serving
um at the very least he should be
suspended pending this inquiry and there
is a question mark over issue sunak
himself you know 100 days into his job
he had a very bad appointment of swella
bravaman who had broken the ministry or
a code and he put her back in office we
know now about Nadeem zahawi he he
apparently had been told about the tax
problem for the former now chairman of
the conservative party and now he's he's
not suspending his Deputy Prime Minister
with these serious allegations I think
the question marks are now not just
about Dominic Robb but about the Prime
Minister but we heard from dining Street
this morning actually they say principal
dictates that ministers carry on with
their Duty as while any investigation is
ongoing well um I have to say the it
wouldn't happen in a normal job with it
um if you were a civil servant if you
were a journalist if you were in so many
walks of life if the level of these
allegations very serious allegations
made you would you would you were given
gardening leave you wouldn't be at your
desk and you know they are of that
gravity that I really think the Prime
Minister should suspend Dominic Robb we
smog uh Jacoby smog says beware of
snowflakeery
well that's a classic Jacob Reese MOG
comment completely out of touch with
reality I mean that's the problem with
this government I don't think they
understand real people's lives whether
it's the cost of living what's happening
in HS and how you should behave to your
employees uh jQuery smog typifies the
Rishi sunat government that they they're
not in touch with reality yeah
of government isn't that you know people
like Dominic Ralph having to make
critical decisions in the moment he
needs to be able to express himself to
his close team
I was a cabinet minister and I served
under real pressure you should treat
everybody with respect and frankly the
best way to get the best out of your
Social servants isn't to to bully them
but to thank them and I found that was
the best way uh treat people with
respect and you can work as a team and
you can get best results if you shout
and scream at people surprising enough
you won't get the best out of them
until proven guilty as well aren't you
he's the Justice secretary and you know
who he that nothing has been found
against him at this stage no I'm I'm
more than willing to wait till the uh KC
has been in charge of this review uh
reports to make the Judgment uh but I
still the king's Council the lawyer yeah
the Kings have a bigger part
um but I I do think in the meantime he
should be suspended because the
allegations are so serious and it again
it it goes to the weakness of the Prime
Minister he's not prepared to take the
action when faced with the facts and you
know one of the things we'd like to see
is the independent minister of advisor
on ethical standards look into what the
Prime Minister knew and when with
respect to these allegations of bullying
against Dominic Rob did he appoint
Dominic Robb knowing these serious
allegations were there
um talk to me about the social care
announcement so many of our viewers this
morning will have seen uh you appearing
in our Jason Farrell's report 200
million pounds being offered to put this
plan into effect
um is that enough money
it's nowhere near enough I mean I
welcome that there's some movement at
long last but independent analysis has
shown we need two billion pounds over
the next four years to start putting
some of this this Scandal right I mean
there are children out there people who
in care in Care Home people who uh
children who are not being looked after
properly and that should be a scandal
now Society these young people are some
of the most vulnerable in our society
um their whole lives will be blighted if
they're not treated proper as a child
and a young person and one thing that
all Democrats want to do is not just
about money it's about the system and
I've been a strong advocate of
supporting kinship carers and my liberal
Democrat colleague vanira Wilson has put
forward a set of proposals a proposed
law that would give kinship careers
grandparents uncles aunts brothers and
sisters close uh relatives to the young
person when the parent can't take care
give them more rights and more support
that must be the way forward where
you're supporting the family and the
fact that government doesn't doesn't
seem to get that is quite shocking and
we have a kinship care actually on the
program later on to talk to us in more
detail about this now Boris Johnson
never far from controversy as we know
said yesterday that anyone who suspects
he covered up lockdown parties while PM
is out of their mind are you out of your
mind
I think I think it's more likely Boris
Jones now his money he's in total denial
isn't he you know the thing about Bryce
Johnson right and the reason why I think
he behaves so shockingly with those
parties in in number 10 allegations of
sex in the basement during his time
there you know
um I I thought him we have to not not
him but you know he was in number
tenants he's his building uh and he
allowed these parties in this Behavior
to go on during lockdown when everyone
else is abiding by the rules the fact
that he he says that shows that he just
deceives himself just as much as he sees
the rest of the world
um the National Audit office examining
the decision to spend 220
000 pounds of taxpayers money for the
prime minister's legal defense bill
um
if it's proven that some of the delay in
him cut at this coming to the fore was
as a result of Mr Johnson's actions
should he be expected to pay some of
that money back
well I think he really needs to be held
to account better than happened so far
you know I personally think he was unfit
for office from day one I was shocked
that the conservative party uh put him
into into power and the way he then
treated so many people and lied so so
many people and made such a hash of
being prime minister is actually staying
on the conservative party and although
he's now been thrown out not before time
I think he needs to be fully held to
account and all these various
investigations that there are now into
what happened need to conclude and
whatever the recommendations they come
for with I think they should be
implemented okay always great to see you
thank you very much indeed thanks a lot
sarad and as I was saying you can see
sir Ed uh in the report uh by Jason
Farrell a little bit later on in the
program quick look at the papers for you
now and the guardian carrying an
exclusive report which says the National
Audit office is looking into how 220 000
pounds just talking about that won't we
have taxpayers money was used to pay for
the legal defense of Boris Johnson
during the investigation into breaking
lockdown laws the eye looking at the
prospect of former PM list trust
returning to the spotlight and
potentially causing new conservative
party riffs and the Daily Telegraph
picking up on the RAF being in crisis
over its drive for diversity tomorrow is
here good morning good morning pressure
mounting on Dominic Royal and the Prime
Minister that's right on Richardson x
100 days in power is Dominic raw proving
a major problem for the Prime Minister
look there's lots of pressure now for
him to be suspended while this
investigation carries on into whether he
bullied civil servants there are said to
be up to 24 complaints the government
have admitted that there are at least
eight and the message I get from number
10 is that the long-standing convention
is that ministers stay in post while
they're being investigated look at
pretty Patel when she was investigated
and look at Nadeem zahari the party
chairman who was investigated for a
short period they tend to stay in post
they say there's no precedent for that
but you've got lots of people saying if
this happened in any other Walk of Life
with allegations of this severity people
saying they felt suicidal then they
would be asked to step aside until the
investigation is complete the Prime
Minister continuing to get questions on
this when he wants to be talking about
other things the government is doing and
of course he's had a very difficult
first few months in power but when you
ask his allies what his achievements
they say the big one is the first thing
he did after taking over from Liz trust
which is basically getting the markets
back on track bringing in a spending
squeeze to get the public finances back
on track they think that's his biggest
achievement so far and he's outlined the
five things he wants to do in the next
couple of years yeah but what about the
unions they're saying that he needs to
be put to one side for now because those
in the department are not potentially
not safe while he's there that's right
wrong words very strong words um both
from Dave Penman of the the Civil
Service Union and from labor and the
liberal Democrats you say that if
someone is accused of bullying they
shouldn't be just left there potentially
to carry on doing it while this
investigation carries on that people may
be at risk
um Dominic Robb of course says he's
behaved professionally he's essentially
said that he he's demanding he expects
the best from people but he doesn't
think he ever crossed the line into
bullying I'm sure Rishi soon acts
desperate for this all to be wrapped up
pretty quickly but people are still
giving evidence to this inquiry so it's
hard to see how it will be brought to a
close until at least the end of this
month hi again everybody uh you're very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News Thursday morning a
petition signed by 100 thousand members
of the public nursing staff and patients
will be delivered to 10 Downing Street
today calling on the prime minister to
pay nurses fairly joining us now is the
cross bench peer Lord Chris a former NHS
Chief exec hello Chase Ray good to see
you thanks for joining us on the program
this morning
um how do you think the NHS is being
um
helped dealt with at the moment
well I think we've obviously got a
crisis a really serious crisis
um can I just qualify that I've talked
to quite a lot of people in recent days
and not everything is bad you know so
there are
um you know a million encounters between
patients in the NHS every day and some
people get very good care so let me just
make that clear nevertheless this is
really serious and I think one of the
big problems here is that people don't
is morale actually it's it's it's it's
not just the pressure people don't seem
to have any hope that things are going
to change so I know the prime minister
is trying to get a grip on this but I
think there's there's more to do and
settling the strike and moving on is
very much part of it
yeah I mean the government's uh we hear
quite a lot about talking about
reforming of the NHS what do you think
that could look like
well I think in some things that are
being said at the moment are very good
which is a much more care being provided
in communities and in people's homes and
here's an interesting point which is
that actually that is going to depend
very much on nurses nurses in the
community nurses District nurses
practitioner nurses nurses can play a
much bigger role in the NHS in the
future so I think you know two of the
things are about a much bigger
investment in the community a much
bigger investment in nurses but let me
also say there's a paradox here which is
you can't improve the NHS by improving
the NHS let me explain what I mean if
you think about where a lot of the
problems that coming to the NHS come
from they come from things that aren't
in the nhs's control they're about
stress they're about obesity they're
about air pollution and so on so we
actually need a great it's not just
reforming what happens within the NHS
it's reforming what's happening within
Society so that we've got a society that
promotes and creates health I for
example have got a bill in front of the
House of Lords about improving housing
because actually damp and dangerous and
cold housing is very bad for health so
there's got to be reform within the NHS
facing much more to the community but
also reform in the uh in wider Society
so that employers and others take a
bigger role in promoting health
um let's talk about nurses you brought
up nurses pay their nurses um on strike
for the first time basically in their
history for a national strike using food
banks basically just can't cope is what
we're being told and then we look at the
other end of the scale and NHS bosses
are earning you know 255 000 pounds more
certainly almost all of them more than a
hundred thousand pounds looking at
another one to hear from Saint Thomas's
the guy in charge there 178
000 pounds there's quite a disparity
there isn't there
oh there is a disparity I have to say
it's not as big a disparity as you get
in a lot of private sector companies you
ought to remember that guys St Thomas's
has a turnover of I think
um was somewhere around about three
quarters of a billion pounds so this is
ftse 100 territory so actually you've
got to be dealing with a whole lot of
major complexities so I think you can
argue for support those salaries but the
uh and the difference between them and
and nurses is only something like
whatever that works out at about six or
seven times whereas in Industry it may
be a hundred times so let's be clear
there's big differences there
um but what you're saying about nurses
is absolutely right
um I do believe they need to be better
paid they need to be better career
opportunities they need to be able to
work to their full potential and I do
hear nurses and I've done quite a lot of
work with nurses in recent years saying
that if they let us work to the level at
which we're trained we could make a
bigger difference and this is nurse
practitioners it's people in the
community of people in districts I do
think promoting and developing nurses is
one of the the golden bullets if I can
put it like that that will actually help
health services not just in this country
actually but it improve this is a this
is a global issue that we still don't
treat nurses as the true professionals
that they are
and in this present pay round do you
think that nurses then should be treated
as a special case
well I would do so but then I I've only
looked at nurses so of course I would I
would say that so I can't argue about
teachers and all the rest of it I just
don't know the circumstances but I think
the most important thing is that the
prime minister's I believe is trying to
get a grip I think he does need to get a
grip and I think part of that is not to
let this strike go on much longer both
the both sides need to give there needs
to be a negotiation there needs to be an
understanding of how you're going to
take this forward and the people need to
be given some hope and some vision for
the future and I'm sure that vision is
about a much more community-based
service so that hospitals can do the
things that are only hospitals can do
because hospitals are fantastically
important but an awful lot of the care
that needs to be given can be given in
the community with improving technology
and over five or ten years we'll see
that happening
um final thought before I let you go um
some suggestions that we should be uh
paying to use the GP even paying to use
accident and emergency your thoughts on
that well I think I nearly said that's
nonsense but I think the difficulty here
is if you paid use a GP well you'll end
up in accident an emergency when you
instead of doing that unless you may
people pay for that but the issue here
is let's sort out how you deliver
services and then decide how you pay for
it people jump to wanting to decide it's
not an economic issue this it's not a
financial issue it's a health issue how
do we want Health Services to be
delivered in the future and once we're
clear about that then let's have the
discussion uh about funding but don't
funding and financing but don't jump to
funding and financing Solutions because
you'll find that you've just done
something you've changed the finances
other problems pop up you haven't solved
the problem and we'll have crises like
this year after year you need
fundamental change in the way the
service is delivered